have you heard of something mike this is
a new thing that's been coming up called
cancel culture
no it's crazy right let's cancel culture
so cancel culture is this thing right
it's nuts right
where they will find anything you've
ever done
or anything that you may do regardless
of context and try to make sure you
can't ever make a living again
that's not true they don't do that to
democrats well it's funny you say that
sarah silverman as we've spoken of many
times on this show it's one of our
one of probably if you listen her old
stuff when aunt you know when
when jimmy kimmel used to write stuff
for her uh probably one of the
raunchiest
very raunchy comedians she really was i
mean you know talk about
jokes race jokes all kind of jokes lost
her virginity to kevin brennan
yeah i always like to
well she um is upset because
they've been going through her stuff and
they have been um
they have been not happy with stuff that
she's found now this culture that she's
helped build by calling everybody racist
and everybody ever make a joke if
they're white they're racist and all
that stuff
is a little upset so here's a little
clip from i think she forgot what show
she was on doesn't really so she's
worried about getting canceled because
they're digging into her past
yeah has anyone told her she's
let me think she knows her name's
silverman okay so she's fine what are
you whining about
it's the absolutist
ness of the party i am in
that is such a turn off to me the party
that you helped push the party you
helped create
the way you got other people kicked off
the way you called other people racist
the way your entire twitter is saying
how white people are bad
so so basically it was funny when it was
other people but now you're getting a
taste
of it and it's not fun anymore of the
party i am in
that is such a turn off to me
it's so [ __ ] elitist you know for
something called
is sarah silverman
calling other people elitist
okay all right let's see where this goes
[ __ ] elitist
you know for something called
progressive
it allows for zero progress
it's all or nothing no steps toward
all or [ __ ] nothing that you helped
create that you helped build
the person who became famous and then
closed the door behind her nobody
you and i aren't allowed to make the
jokes she used to make
again righteousness porn
and i've been thinking about this a lot
just in general
i i just i don't know that i want to be
associated with any party
i really i think i don't want to be
associated with
any party anymore okay babe who are you
going to vote for though yeah
who you voting for sarah you don't want
to be associated huh you you don't
see what's happening is that we were
saying we've been saying this since we
started the show
the mob might eat you last but they're
gonna eat you
and they're doing it now and see that's
your biggest problem you helped create
this monster now you're going back
it's the bill mar thing it's the same
thing as the bill mar thing you know
but she's just whining was she canceled
did she lose anything or are people just
bitching on twitter just bitching on
twitter so she's incessated with
any party anymore it just
it comes with too much baggage
every party it comes with so much
[ __ ] baggage where was this
enlightenment during trump's tenure as
president
yeah where was this where was this
enlightenment when you were calling
white people
for making jokes where was it and also
another uh
question um if you don't mind
uh what about all the people who have no
political affiliations
who you guys still try to gang up on and
cancel because they won't
they won't tow your party's line like
how many people have you
tried to cancel that aren't even
involved in politics
what about when the internet mocked you
mercilessly because people were spray
painting fios
things remember this in new york there
was spray painting of the fios thing and
you were taking a picture and seeing
another poorly drawn
unironically by the way it wasn't a joke
it was literally
it was either that or like the gas
company yeah when they spray paint the
street to let you know that they
inspected that
thing that no
ideas can be taken at face value
and without ideas what are we
but that's what we were saying and
that's what we have and a lot of people
have been
saying now you care about ideas when you
were [ __ ]
talking about people that had
uncomfortable things to say or things
that you didn't like
you were lambasting them you were
[ __ ] going after them on twitter
you were destroying them you and [ __ ]
said your little boy seth rogen
all of you people you made your you made
your [ __ ] career
on being edgy and saying things that
were uncomfortable
and now you're realizing that you can't
do that anymore
because of the culture that you helped
create i don't buy it i don't even think
she's realizing that i don't even think
she's making a point this is a little
self-pity party because people were
probably saying mean things to her on
twitter that's all this
is she's not gonna change she's not
different she's not enlightened now
she's not this isn't like oh wow oh now
all of a sudden you come here she's not
coming around she's having a little pity
party
because people said mean words to her on
twitter because she probably did
blackface 2 at some point
she did yeah she did that's right she
did we've shown the pic she's done
blackface
without a common truth how can we talk
about it
you know republicans might hear an idea
that they would totally agree with
but if it comes from aoc then they hate
it
well yeah because aoc is calling them a
bunch of racist baby killers
[ __ ] kids in cages which we're gonna
get into here in a second
but because of that all of a sudden now
no i don't want to hear any ideas from
you that moment's
past you lost that chance a long time
ago
yeah and we're not the ones who gave up
on on being
like courteous you guys did like
you know but they still want you to
believe that like donald trump was
the last straw and that's when they
start but like
donald trump wasn't the problem he was a
symptom
of the problem he wouldn't have been
again everybody thinks donald trump won
he didn't these people
lost their open um unapologetic hatred
of regular flyover state people
is what made them like they lost they're
hateable people right
from aoc then they hate it and of course
you know to be
honest when i hear an idea that comes
from a republican
it's suspect to me
we because of the culture you
[ __ ] created yeah you guys fostered
this attitude
and then now it's now it's too much
you could you know it's easy to bag on
republicans and i think they should be
bagged on sometimes we bag on them
plenty
it's easy to bag on republicans right
it's easy to do all that
but you were the people that would put
your fingers in your ears when we were
saying stuff
look i always use the gay marriage thing
as this point right like
when people were when people were
talking about hey you know gays just
want to get married let him get married
you actually had a lot of republicans on
your side
more libertarians leaning republicans
but there was a lot of republicans like
yeah let him get married i don't really
care
but when it comes to anything that we're
saying or the right wing for example to
say i'm only saying we but
that the right wing is saying you are
[ __ ] never wanted to hear and don't
pretend like you're going to start
listening to it now
we all put we all put too much [ __ ] on
this stuff
we no longer are able to be a nation of
ideas
you don't get to say that now
the people that have been de-platformed
for [ __ ] giving ideas get to say that
you helped get people kicked off of
things you're the one that helped push
the narrative
you're the one that we're retweeting
that you're taking over the planet
you don't get to say that sarah well
yes she does i get it but you know what
i mean
they run the show man it's not changing
she's not enlightened like i said she
she had a rough day and she went out
cried on her little podcast it doesn't
mean
anything nothing she's not coming to
jesus she's not having a moment
she's just pissing and moaning like
women do
um because they have no self-awareness
you know what i find funny about this is
she does a podcast with multiple cameras
but they're all filmed like with the
phone
not turned that's the thing i don't
understand why why are all her camera
angles like an instagram video
because she's yeah probably